who Seth Rogen who did Seth Rogen write
Superbad with I wrote it with my friend
Evan Goldberg who I still work with to
this day we met at in bar mitzvah class
when we were 12 years old and we went to
high school together we wrote Pineapple
Express together we direct uh there's
the end together in the interview and we
produce together
um he's still uh one of my very best
friends and we still write together we
start writing Superman we were like 13
years old basically when we started high
school it's like embarrassing how
similar it is to the finished movie that
we made that is still what many consider
one of the best things I've ever had
anything to do with I've had to Grapple
a lot with the fact that I did a lot of
that when I was like 15 years old so
yeah